this is Miguel concepción editor
gamespot with some footage from the
initial hours of my review playthrough
of drag quest arrows - while some of you
might have already checked out the
recent demo of this warriors spin-off
sequel many of the following scenes will
still be new to you that includes
thorough exploration of a desert map a
ton of new monsters and the appearance
of a few familiar dragon quest
characters new to hero's turn ago for
instance proves to be a useful squad
mate don't let that abacus on a stick
fool you
it packs a punch
watch this little fella
[Music]
from what I've played so far Dragon
Quest heroes - looks to be much more
than just another warrior spin-off with
a new set of DQ characters the
battlefields are much larger this time
around and there are improvements to the
monster minion feature I was especially
surprised by the ability to transform
into some of the larger enemies for a
limited time if you enjoyed this Dragon
Quest Heroes 2 footage let us know into
the discussion below while you're here
give us a thumbs up and subscribe to our
Channel along with an awesome history of
persona video you can watch right now
we'll have more dragon quest footage for
you soon thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I hope you're ready today
thanks God
let's go
trap door with a hint of
[Music]
[Applause]
the enemy forces are divided now is our
chance to capture the king of ABBA
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
turn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
leave it to me let's go we're
unstoppable
[Music]